gérard lagarde toujours bonjour vous
êtes le président de l'upm l'union des
parents d'élèves de la martinique
l'association de parents d'élèves
majoritaire chez nous alors en tant que
tel en tant que président de l'upm mais
aussi l'association elle même
quelles relations entretenez-vous avec
les éditer des diverses municipalités et
celle des trois communautés
d'agglomération de la martinique nous
entretenons des relations régulières
cordiale qui sont souvent dans le cadre
de relations contractuelles
c'est à dire que certaines collectivités
lorsqu'elle met en place par exemple des
délégations de services publics font
appel à l'upm pour la composition de
leur commission consultative des
services publics locaux donc mais
certaines intercommunalités aussi je
salue notamment l'espace sud qui a fait
un gros travail à ce niveau là et donc
nous nous ce cadre nous intervenons et
nous privilégions bien sûr la défense de
l'intérêt général plutôt que l'intérêt
particulier
donc ce sont des relations qui sont
régulières fréquente est ouvert et
souvent cordiale eux sont toujours
difficiles à grands pas nous n'avons pas
toujours le dernier mot jean veut dire
puisque vont nous sommes là pour
défendre l'intérêt des élèves et des
parents d'élèves
et il y a des fois des incompatibilités
notamment si on prend l'exemple de la
l'accompagnement pour les enfants dans
le transport scolaire pour les enfants
de moins de 6 ans donc depuis de
nombreuses années nous essayons de
convaincre les édilité au travers de des
intercommunalités qu'il faut de cet
accompagnement donc nous essayons de
travailler sur la base de relations
cordiales franchement irresponsable nous
n'avons pas à donner des envies d
affaires de dictats nous essayons de
défendre la position des parents
d'élèves des élèves et surtout toujours
en respectant les valeurs de l'upm à
savoir la responsabilité évidemment vous
êtes en relation avec tout le monde vous
ne faites pas de politique vous a lui
même quelle que soit la couleur ou
l'idéologie ou le camp auquel appartient
tel ou tel maire ou tel conseiller
communautaire au président de communauté
d'agglo voilà c'est exactement cette
vidéo ce qui est important pour nous
c'est la politique c'est le m2 lui même
c'est la martinique c'est ce qui est
important et donc quel que soit celui
qui en poste et quelles que soient les
politiques qu'ils sont
parce qu'on en a vu un succès 10 15
dernières années y compris au niveau des
politiques rectorales quelles que soient
nos interlocuteurs nous nous devons
défendre l'intérêt des élèves les
terrains des parents d'élèves et de
l'étirer supérieur de la martinique en
fait parce que par le passé on a vu des
présidents d'associations de parents
d'élèves
ici ou là je ne pointe pas du doigt
spécialement l'upm mais le poème en tant
que journaliste j'ai eu à connaître ça
qui était par ailleurs des militants
politiques alors il mélangeait pas
forcément les deux mais enfin à l'épaule
effectivement nous avons des militants
récent remonte à longtemps nous avons
aujourd'hui des militants politiques
qu'ils soient de tous les corps dans
tous les bords j'ai envie d'y en tout
cas les principaux camps qu'on va dire
des rues qui veut que l'on retrouve en
martinique
on ne demande pas de carte politique
contre entre à l'upm ce qui nous la
seule chose qui nous importe c'est la
volonté que le parent d'élève à de
s'engager auprès d'eux de son enfant
d'abord puis aussi auprès de la
communauté pour faire en sorte qu'un
responsabilités on puisse trouver des
solutions qui soient pérennes alors ben
dans la même foulée un peu puisque nous
sommes en campagne électorale
est-ce que vous avez des adhérents
militants bon donc au départ
initialement de la cause des parents
d'élèves mais qui peuvent se retrouver
ici ou là candidats colistiers ou encore
mieux peut-être être en tête de quelques
listes pour ces élections municipales
bon et est ce que vous même en tant que
président de l'upm vous estimez vous
souhaiter qu'il y en ait davantage qui
s'impliquent d'une manière ou d'une
autre dans les affaires municipales et
communautaires d'agglomération c'est
vrai que nous souhaitons qu
effectivement le martiniquais s'engage
dans la chose publique est d'abord
s'engager auprès de son enfance engagé
dans la communauté éducative
et puis pourquoi pas effectivement alain
petit peu plus loin dans les
municipalités de toutes les instances de
décision pas seulement au niveau
politique ça peut être aussi au niveau
associatif dans les clubs sportifs les
associations culturelles
il faut que nous menti nous
puissions nous engager à côté de notre
jeunesse
et c'est extrêmement important mais sans
sans couleur politique quelconque
l'objectif c'est bien de trouver les 10
nominations commun qui nous permettront
de progresser ensemble mais
vous avez déjà alors on peut même
étendre par exemple à la ctm lors des
dernières mandatures vous avez eu des
militants des adhérents qui
effectivement sont dans des conseils
municipaux ou untel à l'assemblée de
martini qui peuvent être vos relais est
également vous ramener un certain nombre
de choses qui souffre qui se disent
peut-être pas forcément devant les
caméras en plénière mais en coulisses ou
voilà dans une commission dont nous
n'avons jamais c'est pas ce type ne
rétablissons pas ce type de rapport
chacun est libre et responsable de son
engagement politique n'y a aucune
collision face au lobbying dérangeante
auprès des populations le seul lobbying
que nous fassions s'élève de fait en
sorte que les instances fonctionne
correctement que la parole disent eux
ils disent autres puissent être entendu
qu'il y ait un dialogue social des
relations sociales au sein des
établissements et des municipalités ou
des collectivités qui se croient de
qualité c'est la seule chose que nous
pourrions sur laquelle nous pourrions
agir mais nous n'avons pas à passer en
dessous passé par derrière non nous
souhaitons justement à l'upm cultiver la
transparence la responsabilité et fait
en sorte que nos positions soient connus
de tous et que l'on puisse prendre des
positions anti nick qu'ils soient qui le
soit sur la base de d'éléments clairs
des indicateurs précis de donner ici ce
qu'il nous manque le plus aujourd'hui
c'est la transparence et la mise à
disposition de à tous les acteurs des
éléments clés et le rôle de l'élu menti
qu'elle ne se limite pas à la
réalisation d'équipements à mettre à la
disposition de l'éducation nationale le
rôle de ligne mantes mickey va bien au
delà de ça alors on va on va y venir on
va y venir juste une question avant de
d'évoquer cet aspect au gérard la guerre
président de l'upm
ce que je veux dire c'est que quelque
part
est-ce que les vous estimez vous avez
suffisamment d' écoute auprès justement
des décideurs politiques
voilà est-ce que de ce point de vue là
y'a pas y'a pas une démarche
supplémentaire sans faire de lobbying
parce que bon j'ai utilisé ce terme mais
nous estimons que parce que quelquefois
on a l'impression que vous qui défendez
souvent vous entends vous même
personnellement le président de l'upm
toujours mettre en avant l'intérêt
général avant certains intérêts
particuliers ou quelquefois même
partisan partisans donc voilà est-ce que
ça
non seulement nous ne sommes pas le
niveau des coudes que nous attendons
n'est pas encore à la hauteur de ce que
nous espérons c'est clair il faut faut
que l'on se rende compte
en martinique et quel que soit le
secteur d'activité dans lequel on est
que c'est par le dialogue la
transparence et la concertation que l'on
pourra élaborer ensemble des projets qui
ont un sens il faut donner du sens à nos
actions et s'exclame important donc oui
nous poursuivons et nous allons
poursuivre et rien ne va nous arrêter
pour faire en sorte que nous puissions
contribuer à la conscientisation de la
population martiniquaise y compris
celles des élus qui aujourd'hui je dois
à l'intérêt que le creusement le
reconnaître qu' aujourd'hui s'engage
mais ne connaissent pas l'étendue de
leurs responsabilités en matière
éducative d'éducation de chiens éducatif
il y a deux de grandes choses que nous
pouvons faire ensemble sans forcément
nécessiter des moyens extraordinaires
allez pour les deux dernières minutes
qui nous restent gérard la gare
justement concernant les établissements
scolaires alors il ya les bâtiments 1
et puis les conditions d'accueil alors
certains même ajouterait avec ce serait
mieux en ayant à l'esprit une volonté de
développement durable respectueux de
l'environnement naturel alors justement
de ce point de vue quelles sont les
attentes vos souhaits pour les
prochaines mandatures la de six ans qui
vont être entamées dans quelques jours
concernant le bâti scolaire et comme on
s'adresse jeudi si la vidéo au maire la
première chose c'est que l'on se sente
de l' isolement et que les maires
comprennent que il faut aujourd'hui
aller vers la mutualisation et que nous
devons impérativement mettre en place un
schéma des plantations d
dix écoles primaires qui tiennent compte
de l'évolution démographique qui tienne
compte du risque sismique qui tiennent
compte de l'état du bâti et que l'on
puisse réaliser des équipements qu'ils
soient aux normes qui effectivement nous
permettre de réduire notre consommation
énergétique
il y avait là il ya des chantiers nous
permettent également de mieux accueillir
nos enfants c'est extrêmement important
média à faire là il ya ce qu'il faut il
ya énormément à faire une programmation
je rappelle qu'il ya une programmation
qui a été fait dans le cadre du contrat
de plan etat-région 2015 2020 qui
prévoyait la construction au lard
consolidation de huit écoles primaires
par an et nous n'avons jamais vu ces
huit écoles primaires pendant donc il y
a bien des raisons qui justifient alors
c'est peut-être le manque de moyens
financiers
mais aujourd'hui nous savons qu'avec 10
% normalement on peut construire une
école pourquoi parce qu'il ya les fonds
dernier et lé fonds feder pour ya les
fonds de la cité m également qu'il
intervient dans l'accompagnement dhr il
y a lieu alors ya le bâti et puis il y à
le bâtir vos yeux il ya aussi ces ou
tout aussi important mais tout aussi
important c'est le vivre ensemble c'est
tout ce que l'on doit fait en osier qui
est de la responsabilité des
collectivités locales notamment au
travers des plans de dpe d'été donc sur
les plans d'entraînement et de
développement des plans éducatif les
programmes éducatifs de développement
territoriaux qui doivent permettre de
faire un état des lieux du potentiel de
la commune surtout sur toutes ces
infrastructures qui doit permettre de
traiter nos enfants les élèves de du le
dit ou dimanche tout au long de l'année
donc ça veut dire qu'il faut qu'il y ait
une vraie politique qui sera menée
il faut que lier ce que nous attendons
qu'il y ait dans dans les municipalités
déchantent qui soit élaboré avec les
associations de parents d'élèves qui
permettent de justifier enfin en tout
cas d'élaborer de dire quels sont les
droits et les devoirs du parent et de
l'élève
il faut que l'on puisse sans actualiser
ces écolos que la route la qualité de la
relation sociale au sein des
collectivités nous garantissent le fait
qu'il n'y ait aucun blocage
d'établissements scolaires parce que
nous considérons qu'aujourd'hui ce n'est
pas par le blocage que nous allons
relever à faire en sorte que notre
jeunesse martiniquaise soient devant
merci gérard la guerre président de
l'union des parents d'élèves de la
martinique d'avoir répondu à nos
questions dans ce ca au caddie réalisé
par paul eric tout ça